everybody wants to zoom now and it's
this whole new world that I find I'm
getting a little this is fun
but I have so many people reaching out
to me saying let's zoom let's have a
talk about that on Zoom and I don't know
what the etiquette is it's weird it's a
big screen it's not ideal I've been
doing stand-up on it and um it's just
the shows are they're fine um and it is
like I did say the other day you know
this wasn't as bad as I thought it was
gonna be and if the world doesn't ever
return to normal like I could see myself
like quitting because this isn't good
enough
the-the-the laughter lag when you tell a
joke in the two seconds you question
every you add those two seconds up and
you'll feel really bad about yourself
because you just I need the immediate
laughter what are you how are you doing
without immediate laughter i man I
notice that whenever I'm passing my wife
or one of my kids and they're on a zoom
call with somebody I get in the
background give me a little something
and I see them laugh and I guess it's
sad
I'm trying to get it where I can but I
notice it too I noticed that there's
this rhythm you can get into I mean
there's some stuff about it I like and I
know that you do you do this to you're
very funny in a situation where there's
not an audience and you're you
understand what's funny without meeting
an audience to tell you but getting last
is just fun you know it's it's fun and
so that's the part and there is a little
weird in zoom there's a little delay so
if I think of something funny I actually
way is it worth is it worth it because
there's gonna be a delay as opposed to
just saying it you know it's so much
riskier it really is changing comedy
it's making it a lot less satisfying to
do and I'm looking into other things I'm
like should I go back to school and be a
therapist because they seem to be like
really necessary right now I mean that
only people I'm talking to I'm just it's
not like I'm I'm it reminds me of
talking to boys in high school where I
would like crawl away to like get away
so I could whisper on the phone and now
it's just I'm talking to Donna about you
know how my mom had a weird tone with me
yesterday but I'm zooming I'm zooming
everything I am my favorite thing about
zoom and you got to do this when you
look when you're in your next zoom call
you've got to look for this moment cuz
it happens every time you sign off of
the call and you're like this was really
fun thank you so much okay guys we'll
follow up on that
thanks everyone have a great day okay
cool and then just after that call and
then the people looking for the Live
Meeting yes yes it takes about two
seconds literally like like no it's so
it's so funny because I'm noticing it
Izu with all these you know different
celebrities all the different people I
talked to
and I also zoom with you know my
producer and my writers and but
everybody's we all have this thing that
we do in society which is we have a
certain animated you know thing that we
have and then I love it because it takes
a second to find the button and so what
happens is it looks like people have had
a stroke so people but it's people
really are like you know Nicky it was so
great talking to you I love you you're
the best you know take care and I'll see
you and all this madness is over yeah
and then it kind of freezes there
because even after you hit it and you
stuck with that image and so you think
what person didn't give a [ __ ] about me
at all that I just saw who they really
what they really think about me yeah I
see myself to it so don't catch my face
I'm like that's the real you just